here's a little interesting video this
uh the video i'm about to play for you
is of radical republican congressman
matt gates
and he was
very
mildly confronted about the fact that he
continues to insist that trump won on
local tv
and this is being reported
uh sort of all over the place
as matt gates gets humiliating reality
check to his face on live local tv or
on alternate matt gates slapped with
epic reality check after echoing trump's
voter fraud claims
it's not really what happened now i
appreciate i appreciate that gates was
pushed you know challenged at all on his
lies about 2020. but basically what
happens here is gates says i believe
trump won and the interviewer goes yeah
but that would require like a lot of
conspiracy you know a lot of people
acting together
and then gates just spews a ton of
nonsense so it's not it's not a major
reality check let's take a look at it so
you're still maintaining 2020 election
was stolen is are we still going with
that listen i believe that donald trump
won the 2020 election i believe that he
won the election
we can't say that without saying that
there was a gigantic conspiracy across
this country and supervisor of elections
offices everywhere right to make this
happen and we haven't still seen any
evidence that proves that yeah because
so many of the courts that should have
taken those matters up rejected
evidentiary hearings on jurisdiction
grounds i mean i know the affidavits
that came out of michigan regarding the
tcf center in detroit now remember this
brings us back to
affidavits are not evidence and yes
affidavits affidavits can can be
introduced and examined but affidavits
are not actually evidence and this is
just another one of the lines that they
keep repeating it's almost taking me
back to december of 2020. but we have
affidavi affidavits are not strictly
speaking evidence established a factual
basis to be able to go and have
evidentiary hearings but too often i
think
judges just didn't have the courage to
take it up
it's most unfortunate but i'm still
engaged in the fight and election
integrity going forward oh yeah because
florida used to be the laughing stock of
elections and governor desantis fired
the elections officials who didn't run
clean elections and now lo and behold
florida's a model for the country so i
want to bring florida's message and our
story can you imagine florida as a model
for the country um so listen i mean like
it's great that he was asked uh where is
your evidence for that
but at the same time that was not
exactly
a brutal reality check that it's made
out to be now notice the language matt
gates uses he says i believe donald
trump won they are the ones who always
say
facts don't care about your feelings and
yet he believes trump won absent any
actual facts that would point that way
um
one other thing
there is this whole so matt gates has a
lot going on
one of the things is he's being
investigated for the potential child sex
trafficking and all of that he's hired a
child you know a sex crime defense
attorney and all these different things
on the other hand he's also pedaling
around with marjorie taylor green and
telling lies about the election the
third thing is there's still this very
strange story about how he says his dad
was
extorted by someone or there was an
attempt to extort he's also asked about
that during this interview
any updates on the department of justice
investigation
also the one big update is that since we
talked last the individual who had been
indicted for trying to extort me pled
guilty to extorting me and my family and
uh i hope that that's why the wire fraud
yes and i hope that that investigation
is ongoing because other people
literally went on national television
and said they were working with steve
alford in this deal those people should
be the next to be indicted okay so he
hopes but i guess but i guess doesn't
know
if the investigation is still going on
uh it would be really great for one of
these cartoonish trumpian right wingers
to have a really big
fall from grace and we've talked before
about
fishy stuff with marjorie taylor green
and taking two homestead exemptions
which you can only take one and i'm not
going to go back through what a
homestead declaration of homestead is
and and all that but you're only allowed
to have one
that was being investigated
you know did it fall into some kind of
investigative black hole we don't know
um lauren beaubert a whole bunch of
different campaign funds related things
will anything ever come of it we don't
know
uh madison cawthorne whole other thing
you know the russian honeypot i mean we
can't even get into that right now matt
gates the one facing the most serious
criminal charges potentially it would be
a really interesting thing to see
if one of these you know the major
cartoonist trumpets the younger
cartoonish trumpists are people like
these not cartoonists this guy's no
these guys know bill waterson that's for
sure but the the most cartoonish uh
trumpists are beaubert
uh gates green and cothorn at this point
sort of if one of them had a real big
fall from grace particularly if they um
had criminal charges against them or
some other major scandal it would be
interesting to see how trump would react
in general to that group probably
initially saying they're being
railroaded but
over the long term maybe he would sort
of step back from supporting that group
unclear we will see we will follow it
but hey at least they asked matt gates
to try to defend the claim that trump
won in november he didn't do a great job
but he tried